on va commencer en parlant de la
situation qui concerne les bars on a eu
des menaces désolé comme ça de la part
du gouvernement qui veut vraiment
s'attaquer à la situation et éviter les
débordements
on dit qu'il pourrait y avoir
effectivement des amendes des
restrictions pour les bars mais aussi
d'autres lieux les restos les plages les
piscines si ça ne fonctionne pas vous
recevez ça commence ce message là nous
reçoit le message du nouveau ministre la
centif ci on dit aujourd'hui de manière
positive
je pense qu'avec certaines situations du
district dans certains commerces
particulièrement au cours des dernières
semaines je pense qu'il est acquis une
forme de rappel à l'ordre a mentionné
aussi les restaurants puis être ouvert
pour les livraisons ou les commandes à
emporter pendant 14 semaines 5e
seulement aucun problème donc nous
demandons à nos membres et à l'ensemble
de l'industrie de faire sa part dès
l'installation le très bon travail
ada onesta et on veut être certain par
contre que ceux qui commettent des
infractions soient soient punis de
manière à ce que celui-ci comporte de la
bonne manière puissent continuer à
travailler a obligé et a espéré des
journées c'est ça parce que les images
de débordements qu on a vu par exemple
dans ce bar à brossard est ce qu'il y en
a eu des débordements du genre dans les
restaurants moins jusqu'à maintenant je
voudrais en ma connaissance il ya plus
de ce type d'événement comme ça mais
dans la bouche de plus de 20 ghz
établissements de restera de balle à
travers le québec donc je peux pas
savoir exactement ce qui se passe
partout simplement mentionné que le
processus de réouverture depuis quinze
jours en restauration
bungie donc violent dit très justement à
halle en cours de route les inspecteurs
sont là pour donner des avertissements
mais évidemment si on va davantage des
débordements comme ceux qu'on a pu voir
sur certains médias sociaux et il y en a
certains autres médias il va falloir des
sanctions qu'ils soient plus importantes
que les avertissements et je serai au
canada tout à fait d'accord avec des
règles de distanciation ça peut vraiment
fonctionné comme modèle d'affaires pour
des entreprises
on les bat on peut comprendre c'est très
difficile mais pour les restaurants ce
que ça pourrait être rentable voilà la
vraie question et je voudrais que le
québec a choisi de ne pas avoir de
limites de capacité de plutôt y aller
avec un
la question du double mètre qui plus en
accord avec ce que l'on aime et se
présente donc qui présentait un mètre à
un mètre et demi ou des choses comme ça
donc ça permet une certaine adaptation
sur le plancher et je voudrais par
contre que financièrement effectivement
c'est très difficile notre enquête
publiée aujourd'hui montre que près de
59 % des restaurateurs estiment que ça
ne parle plus de ma avant qu'ils
puissent retrouver leur chiffre
d'affaires d'avant la colline 19
évidemment devant du gouvernement une
certaine être parce que il faut bien
comprendre aussi qu'on demande aux
opérateurs et aux restaurateurs de
respecter les mesures de santé publique
parce que c'est seulement arrivent sans
faire ça qu'on va être capable d'ouvrir
plus d'accueillir plus de clients et de
développer un modèle darracq sont encore
plus profitable
oui mais jusqu'à maintenant l'aise c'est
quoi l'état de la situation ce que c'est
la majorité des restaurants qui ont
ouvert il y en a encore qui sont fermin
oui effectivement je voudrais qu'il y en
a qui ont ouvert certains usages et pas
d'autres j'avais 10 % l'industrie pour
lequel s'est terminée qui est fermée les
gens nous indique raquette après enquête
depuis le début avril qui aura pas de
réouverture
il y avait 10 buts avait pour ça qu'ils
mentionnent que dans la mesure où
gouvernement fait certaines
interventions ciblées le délai de loyers
par exemple un étalement de la
subvention salariale et des choses comme
ça ça va faire une vraie différence pour
eux mais je voudrais qu'ils arriveront
le 20 à 25% des districts est vraiment
sérieusement en danger et c'est pour ça
qu'il ya péril en la demeure
et c'est important de respecter les
consignes mais c'est aussi important
pour le gouvernement de nous mais
adéquat ce sont fédéral qu'au provincial
pour le secteur de la restauration
vous avez évoqué les loyers la sas est
un des enjeux importants pourquoi ça
fonctionne pas là et fédérales aux
loyers ça fonctionne pas pour plusieurs
raisons premièrement au québec par
exemple bonnes mesures comptez séduction
commercial de gouvernement a voulu le
présenter dans la loi 61 et banlieue
c'est un problème le pôle adoption cette
loi là à la fin de ce sont en manque
donc le blâmer sur tous les partis
politiques à ce niveau là nous allons
fédéral aussi le fait que il ya un droit
de veto qui donnait aux propriétaires
d'établissements nonobstant à quel point
de qatar est capable de prouver
sa bonne foi sa capacité plus tard à
pelli est également sa volonté d'entrer
dans une entente
ça pose problème ou si l'on est
l'équilibré entre les peuples et d'aller
de geyter est un peu dysfonctionnel et
c'est aussi une des raisons pour
lesquelles il ya pas suffisamment le
restaurateur il n'y a pas suffisamment
de petites et moyennes entreprises ayant
rompu une partie prenante
ça c'est la moitié à peu près là selon
votre enquête c'est relativement peu
avant construite sur le fait que
j'aimerais vous attend vous entendre
c'est les vacances qui sont commencées
pour bien des québécois certains
canadiens
habituellement c'est une grosse période
de l'année évidemment pour les
restaurateurs
on a l'impression que les clients sont
tant au rendez-vous dans plusieurs
régions là on a des échos ça fonctionne
assez bien
est-ce qu'on va éviter une saison
estivale catastrophique ça s'écoute et
peut gérer depuis reste particulièrement
québec mais aussi ailleurs au pays on
sent vraiment le goût la volonté des
gens que tous nous restâmes à certains
que d'un manque de demande de tourisme
international la fermeture des bureaux
vont faire mal à certains centres-villes
ans à montréal québec c'est certain que
je ne veux plus en plus de touristes
intérieur ou québec et les gens veulent
retourner au restaurant on va espérer
que ça se maintiennent et on veut tous
faire en sorte pour pouvoir rester
ouvert et c'est aussi pour ça qu'on
demande au gouvernement de baisser là où
s'arrête la three merci beaucoup
monsieur fr comment fait plaisir